[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días un programa
semanal en el que analizamos los
acontecimientos más destacados de la
actualidad africana Esto es lo que
veremos hoy en senegal amnistía
internacional ha cifrado en 23 el número
de Muertos tras los enfrentamientos
entre policía y manifestantes provocados
por la condenados años de prisión del
opositor usman sunco hablamos con la
directora de la organización para África
occidental y central
Cómo puede África reducir su dependencia
del trigo importado en un momento en que
la explosión de la presa de Nova
kahootca en Ucrania causó una nueva
subida del precio de este cereal les
presentamos una alternativa seriamente
considerada por un número creciente de
gobiernos africanos Y por último vamos a
la costa Oriental africana en Kenia
pescadores de Aldeanos están pagando el
precio de la explotación intensiva de
los fondos marinos por buques
extranjeros
veremos cómo los residentes intentan a
su medida cambiar la situación
a principios de junio senegal fue
escenario de los disturbios más graves
de los últimos años la condena de
usmansoncó principal opositor del
presidente maquisal a dos años de cárcel
por corrupción de menores desencadenó
violentas manifestaciones Los
partidarios de son con numerosos entre
los jóvenes y en los barrios
desfavorecidos denuncian la sentencia
como una estratagema política para
apartarle del poder los enfrentamientos
entre los seguidores de sunco y la
policía dejaron oficialmente 16 Muertos
pero la organización por los Derechos
Humanos amnistía internacional ha
reportado 23 muertos mediante
entrevistas vídeos autentificados
certificados de muerte informes de
autopsia amnistía denuncia el uso
excesivo de la fuerza y exige una
investigación independiente hablamos con
samira daúd directora de la organización
para África occidental y central sobre
lo que ha podido constatar esto nos dijo
en primer lugar en los últimos meses se
ha producido un número impresionante de
detenciones arbitrarias principalmente
de miembros de la oposición y de la
sociedad civil críticos con el gobierno
o con el tercer mandato de maquisal o de
periodistas
hace varios centenares de personas han
sido detenidos y encarcelados
arbitrariamente también hemos asistido a
un uso excesivo de la fuerza en los
últimos días sobre todo desde el anuncio
del veredicto en el caso del principal
opositor usmansonco procesado y juzgado
por violación y amenazas de muerte pero
que fue absuelto de estos cargos y
condenados sin embargo a dos años de
cárcel por corrupción de menores hemos
documentado 23 casos de personas que han
muerto en los últimos días la mayoría
por disparos
en los videos que ha analizado amnistía
Afirma haber visto a civiles armados
atacando a manifestantes junto a las
fuerzas del orden
Este es otro punto que nos preocupa
enormemente ya que la ley senegalesa
obviamente no permite a civiles A menos
que sean miembros de las fuerzas de
seguridad mantener el orden y mucho
menos utilizar armas que pueden
matarlo
[Música]
a través de varios vídeos que sean
difundido hemos visto también algunas
escenas bastante preocupantes de fuerzas
de seguridad que utilizan a
manifestantes incluso a menores como
escudos humanos para intentar disuadir a
los jóvenes de continuar los
enfrentamientos
[Música]
las tensiones en torno al caso son
comenzaron en en 2021 cuando fue
interpelado tras una denuncia por
violación En aquel momento 14 personas
perdieron la vida y sus familias aún no
han recibido justicia pero familiares de
los 23 fallecidos de este mes han
asegurado que lucharán para que se haga
justicia
evidentemente Esperamos que la justicia
haga su trabajo e investigue
adecuadamente para esclarecer los hechos
y dar respuestas a las familias de las
personas asesinadas
[Música]
de las autoridades no voy a prejuzgar el
resultado de estas investigaciones y
espero que los magistrados asuman su
responsabilidades y lleven a cabo estas
investigaciones con imparcialidad y
rigor Pero la actitud general de las
autoridades no inspira confianza Porque
da la impresión del que quieren culpar a
los propios manifestantes de estas
muertes Y esto no es un buen augurio
la responsabilidad
es precaria desde hace 15 días
privado de la libertad de circulación y
de expresión y el país vive con el temor
desde que desde que se produzcan nuevos
actos de violencia cuando las
autoridades lo detengan y lo lleven a
prisión
En mi opinión es muy probable que se
produzca una reacción violenta si se
detiene a osmanco porque creo que el
mensaje que estamos escuchando hoy es
una pérdida de confianza y credibilidad
hacia el poder judicial que por un lado
no ha reconocido O al menos no ha
condenado los actos de violación y
amenazas de muerte por los que osman
sonko fue procesado y de los que ha
estado acusado durante años por
institución
ha condenado Sin embargo a sonco a dos
años de prisión Y entonces lo han
habilitado a presentarse a las
elecciones Así que este veredicto no es
aceptado y su aplicación va a generar
reacciones bastante hostiles Y es muy
significativo Creo yo que las
autoridades aún no hayan aplicado esta
decisión judicial probablemente porque
son muy conscientes de que es bastante
sorprendente por no decir otra cosa
cambiamos de tema para analizar la
independencia y la seguridad alimentaria
en el Continente la semana pasada la
destrucción de la presa de novaka en
Ucrania provocó una nueva subida de los
precios de trigo haciéndote ver que se
repita la situación de 2022 en África la
invasión Ucrania por los ejércitos de
Vladimir Putin y las sequías históricas
que diezmaron miles de toneladas de
cosechas en Europa Canadá e India
provocaron precios récord y una
explosión del precio del pan en este
gráfico podemos ver como han
evolucionado los precios del trigo desde
2021 y podemos observar que en 2022 con
el inicio de la guerra en Ucrania los
precios de esta materia prima se
dispararon y desde entonces se han
mantenido muy altos África es muy
independiente de este cereal que le sale
además muy caro el 65% del trigo que
consume Es importado entre 2018 y 2020
pagó 3700 millones de dólares a Rusia y
1.400 millones a Ucrania Por último el
continente africano consume una media de
70 millones de toneladas de trigo al año
pero el trigo solo se impuso durante el
período colonial y para compensar su
dependencia África dispone de una
alternativa
podría ser la yuca la respuesta a la
cuestión de la soberanía y de la
seguridad alimentaria y económica del
continente africano
para varios gobiernos sobre todo de
África occidental el apoyo a este sector
podría constituir una alternativa sólida
a la dependencia del trigo importado
principalmente de Ucrania y de Rusia
rica en hidratos de carbono la yuca
requiere poca agua y pesticidas y se
cultiva en toda la zona tropical del
continente donde la producción se ha
duplicado desde 2001 consumido en forma
de sémola fermentado o refinado este
tubérculo presenta numerosas ventajas
procesado puede utilizarse como materia
prima para crear una amplia gama de
productos manufacturados desde la
industria alimentaria donde su harina
podría sustituir a la del trigo en el
pan hasta la fabricación de papel y la
industria textil últimamente el
desarrollo del mercado de la yuca
transformada se ha acelerado como
demuestra El ejemplo de Nigeria primer
productor del continente seguido de la
República democrática del Congo
tras la subida de los precios y las
dificultades de abastecimiento de trigo
provocados por el covid-19 y la Guerra
de Ucrania muchos países como Costa de
Marfil Ruanda y gabón están ahora
dispuestos a seguir El ejemplo de
Nigeria y fomentar la producción de
harina de yuca Así que si la oferta
sigue desarrollándose podría satisfacer
la creciente demanda y aliviar el
problema de la dependencia del trigo
importado
sin embargo queda mucho camino por
recorrer antes de que la yuca alcance
todo su potencial ya que pasara una
escala Industrial implica una logística
compleja además aunque los responsables
políticos afirman querer apoyar al
sector nunca han cuestionado su apoyo
masivo a la Industria del trigo sobre
todo a través de subvenciones a la
importación
dejamos África occidental para
dirigirnos a la costa de África Oriental
en Kenia Pescadores y Aldeanos pagan el
precio de décadas de explotación
intensiva de los fondos marinos el
pasado mes de febrero los estados del
océano Índico decidieron prohibir
temporalmente determinadas técnicas de
pesca industrial de atún esta medida fue
criticada por la Unión Europea ya que
muchos barcos franceses y españoles
paenan en esas aguas en el siguiente
reportaje Aldeanos y ongs intentan sin
embargo cambiar las cosas con las
herramientas que tienen
un Maya Lleva más de 20 años pescando en
la costa keniana pero Las capturas están
disminuyendo la culpa la tiene la
sobrepesca en el océano Índico
culpa de todos los barcos industriales
que vienen aquí en nuestro pueblo
tradicionalmente pescamos atún antes Los
Pescadores podían hasta 200 kilogramos
de pescado atún y otras especies
los kenianos no son los principales
culpables de la sobrepesca Pero si son
las principales víctimas los institutos
de investigación analizan Las capturas
del día e intentan encontrar soluciones
locales aunque no pueden influir en
altamar intentan preservar el ecosistema
costero
Esta es una trampa tradicional mejorada
hecha de juncos Y fue diseñada gracias a
las conversaciones que mantuvimos con la
comunidad la desarrollamos juntos desde
entonces hemos observado una mejora cada
vez se capturan menos alevines
cambiando las técnicas de pesca pero
también restaurando lo que se ha
destruido Estas mujeres han recibido
formación del instituto de investigación
para restablecer los manglares
este lugar es bueno para nosotros y
nuestras familias los peces nacen aquí y
crecen en el manglar nuestra comunidad
gana cada vez más dinero Gracias a esto
para la investigadora hace falta más
acción por parte de las autoridades para
movilizar a la gente a lo largo de toda
la costa si el gobierno apoya esos
proyectos y apoya a las comunidades en
particular para ayudarles a ponerlos en
marcha Los Aldeanos los aceptarán tienen
que comprender la importancia de estos
ecosistemas y los beneficios que pueden
obtener de ellos las acciones locales
son esenciales pero solo tendrán
repercusión si se produce una
movilización mundial También entre los
industriales sobre todo en Europa
llegamos al final de esta edición
gracias por su sintonía nos vemos la
próxima semana
[Música]